hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast
atlas of the sars cov2 pro team
i'm alexis krause of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths
and sponsored by xenobiological
for more information about our sponsor
please visit their website at
sinobiological.com
now let's get started i would like to
remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask
question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please click
on the support tab found at the top
right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
i'd like to now introduce our presenter
dr eunin chen
r d manager at xenobiological for a
complete biography on our presenter
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr chen you may now begin your
presentation
well thank you for the organizer for the
introduction and
now let's jump right in with the
presentation
so today i'm going to talk about the
work that we have been doing
for the for the past couple months uh
regarding
uh to create the recombinant protein and
antibodies
against the source cov2 to help us
combat this global pandemic
so before we uh get into the
contents of the talk i would like to
give a quick shout out
about cytobiological so we i think we
are in the industry
known as the recombinant protein company
so we have we are have extensive
experience
regarding recombinant protein and
recombinant antibody expressions
as well as antibody discoveries and
our portfolio comes in both products
from
genes to all the way to elisa elisa kits
as well as crm services which allows us
to
help our clients with their process from
drug
discovery to drug screening and also to
all the way to production and
characterization and
so now we have that out of the way
so the content of the talk is divided
into
basically four topics so firstly we're
going to give a quick review
of the current situation and then i'm
going to talk about
the work that we have been doing to
essentially recreate the source copy to
protein library
in vitro and i'm going to quickly end
the
i'm going to also quickly introduce you
to the bitmap system which is a
high throughput antibody and protein
expression system and lastly
last but not least of course the summary
and
acknowledgement so um the current
situation that we're in so we're in the
uh in the midst of
this kobe 19 pandemic which
it has caused over
740 000 deaths and
with like over 20 million confirmed
cases all over the world
so this is a dire situation and the
culprit for this
pandemic is the source cov2 virus
as indicated in this electron micro
microscope image here but of course um
it's an rna virus but there is of course
more than meets the eye
so the the genome of the source
cov2virus
is comprised of a single stranded rna
and it encodes
about it can be divided into 10
open reading frames and it encodes about
25
proteins the proteins of the source cov2
can be categorized based on their
function as structural proteins which
include nucleocapsid
membrane envelope and the spike protein
which is the
uh which interacts with the host h2
receptor
and is the basically the entry point of
the virus
and of course there's non-structural
proteins which are
uh which include enzymes uh the catal uh
the catalyzed the crucial biological
functions to ensure the survival and
propagation of the virus
and of course there are some excess a
lot of accessory proteins that are
involved
to facilitate the enzymes to carry out
their biological functions
so the proteins no matter the
non-structure or the structural
component of the virus are important
targets
for both diagnostic and
therapeutic agent development purposes
so again so they're basically very good
candidate for drug discovery
and i think based on the scope of the
current
medicine we can divide
the drugs into two categories basically
the biological
biologics and small molecules so
biologics are the
basically antibody and antibody
derivatives that can be
uh generated using different methods and
they basically
target uh the spike protein and they
either
disrupt the spike interaction with the
whole stage two or they just
flag the the virus for the immune system
to
um to clear the virus out of the system
and of course there are small small
molecules uh that can be generated
either by uh compound screening or
structure based design and i think with
the development of artificial
intelligence
this can also be a method to facilitate
the drug discovery process
so basically we obtain um the structure
of an enzyme
for the for instance for the source cov2
and based on the structure um
we perform you know scientists perform a
rational design
and or they us perform a rational design
or screening against
either compound libraries or start from
a compound template
uh to discover small molecules that can
be used to neutralize
the functionalities of these of these
enzymes
um so as you can see in this regard the
high quality recombinant proteins and
recombinant virus proteins are
important starting materials for the
drug discovery process
and of course the proteins are also
important for
development of diagnostic tools
especially
uh for us for the serological
tests of the viruses and now of course
the covariating can be tested using
molecular tests which is accurate but
you know takes a while to uh it takes a
while to develop
and to get the results and so
there's i think there's an urgent need
for uh very uh for reliable serological
uh tests i think the combination of the
two test formats can
really help us get control of the
situation
so to develop the serological tests we
would
we would also require you know high
quality uh
protein material and antibody material
from derived from the
from the source cov2 so of course the
serological
diagnostics of the virus comes in you
know different shapes and forms
um they of course they have their you
know pros and cons in terms of
uh the availability uh
also the time for uh also the time for
development
and and last but not least of course is
the sensitivity
but you know no matter which format of
the test that we
would like to develop i think the a
prerequisite
of obtaining a high sensitivity and high
specific
specificity tests serological tests for
cova-19
it the um it is based on
the the good quantity starting material
which are the
recombinant proteins as well as
as well as antibodies
so um there are several targets on the
virus
that are very good for you know
serological test development
the first one is this nuclear capsid
protein
and interestingly the nucleocapsid
protein of the starch cov2
is actually highly uh we're relatively
highly conserved with that of the
of of the sars spires starch copy virus
which was
which emerged in the in the early 2000s
2003 i believe
and uh us and uh you know based on the
similarities we we can develop
we can use the source antibody
essentially to
to detect sarcoid ii as in an example
shown here
um this antibody which is a rabbit
monoclonal antibody from
our company uh can recognize both uh
sars cov2 and source viruses but has
relatively
very little cross-reactivity
against other coronavirus coronaviruses
and also spike protein is also another
very good target
for antibody development and because for
one thing it has a
very uh wild distribution of linear
b cell epitopes which enables the body
to generate
sufficient immune response against this
protein
and the antibodies derived from the
spike protein can either be used as
detecting antibodies
uh in serological test development or
we can obtain like neutralizing
antibodies for
um therapeutic applications and here is
an example
um showing several uh neutralizing
antibodies that has been
uh discovered during the process
from the literature during the uh past
few months which demonstrates
the notion that the spike protein is a
inevitably hot target for the source
cov2 virus
so as i mentioned earlier recombinant
proteins are very useful
powerful tools um for both drug
discovery
and serological asset development so
that's
our so that is the reason why
we have devoted most of our majority of
our efforts during the past
few months um to develop these proteins
as the recombinant protein format and to
essentially reconstitute a source called
v2 protein library
using our platforms so basically to give
a
quick recap of the technique of protein
recombinant protein expression
so basically we use a tar we have a
target gene and we
um we introduce the gene
into host cell uh with a vector
and the whole cell can then uh and then
it can trigger the
you know whole cell protein production
machinery
to overexpress the the protein of
interest
so and we can uh obtain the proteins
through purification methods
so at sciento biological we mainly use
these three
platforms for a recombinant protein
expression
and i think during this um during the
times of pandemic
it is the very the speed is a key
so it's very important that we develop
the virus proteins
quickly um and that we are
we just have the i think we just have
the capacity to do that
uh i think we uh previously would take
as only a very short period of time
uh in couple in in the in the range of
two weeks to develop
proteins against uh influenza and zika
viruses
and and this time i think we uh we are
the first
company to uh publicly
to to produce this uh recombinant source
rbd
uh kobe 2 spike rbds uh in just 12
uh just 12 days upon the publication of
this sequence
and because of this you know a robust
platform that we have established
and we have also um
created you know virus proteins from
different viruses and so this uh
so here is the link to the
viral antigen bank we call the probi
so this is a good collection of reagents
for you know virus research we have
over 800 proteins available and we also
have elisa kits
and antibodies against
over like 350 string of
different viruses so um so this is a
good collection of tools
and if you're interested you can find
more on this
webpage so the challenges for the
covenanting
antigen development or for any other
virus protein development is
so firstly of course the speed is as i
mentioned earlier speed is the key
so we would choose systems that can
both preserve the biological function
functionalities of the protein and
obtain the protein
during a relatively shorter period of
time so
in this case the heck 293 and e coli
might be prioritized
but we can also use the insect cell as a
backup plan
and in terms of culture methods the
stable cylon development could take
for the heck 293 or uh the cho cell
lines can take a
month to establish uh but the transient
transfection method will allow us
the obtaining of a recombinant protein
in a relatively
fast fashion so that's the so this is
the go-to method
that we use for for this in denver as
well
so and of course the quantity of the
protein should not be compromised
i think the quality has reflected in two
regards
first is the uh we should produce
protein with
uh relevant biological activities uh
which means that
so so we should you know we should pay
attention to the first translation of
modifications
and uh of course if there is any uh you
know cleavage of the protein by
uh certain enzymes that and to to put
them into like two subunits like the
case of the
stars kobe 2 spike or the influenza h a
virus
h a proteins and if there are any like
mutations we need to pay attention to
and we can produce the protein what kind
of formats like
basically the the choices of uh affinity
tags
are important as well and to uh to eat
to make sure the tags do not interfere
with the
biological uh activity of the proteins
and of course um uh we would also focus
on you know which domains of a protein
we would like to go uh
explore first um so
uh so the bio so this uh so the
biological
reactivity will dictates the whole
system and the design of the protein
and if any engineering methods that we
would apply
and also to predetermine you know what
kind of assay format that we would like
to take
of course with that we would also try to
minimize
batch to batch variations which is um
actually a
it's actually a problem for you know
these transient
infections as infection methods uh the
proteins you know comes in different
shapes and formats and they uh with
their
uh characteristics in the structure they
could
potentially impose some difficulties for
us uh they can prove
they might be prone to aggregation and
degradation and there might be
you know activity fluctuations between
batch to batch
so this require us to optimize the
transfection vector and the methods to
introduce the gene into the cells
and make the cells in a you know
cultural condition as stable as possible
and of course last but not least to
optimize the purification methods
um to minimize damage of the protein
during the uh during the extraction
process
and lastly of course is the quantity
because the proteins are used you know
by different people at a different scale
and they should be shipped maybe like
all over the world so
we would need uh so we would need to
produce the protein at small scale
in this case the you know the flasks um
shaker flasks or we can produce the
protein at media
intermediate level using these missiles
the bioreactors
and we can also we also have like these
gigantic
500 liter and thousand liter bioreactors
for transient protein expression as well
to meet the
demand of a large quantity of the
proteins
so um with that and with all the
with the established expression systems
we are
gradually starting to map the uh source
cov2
protium essentially and
so here as uh as you can see we have
successfully produced uh several enzymes
of the source cov2
some non-structural proteins uh the of
course and of course the nuclear capsid
and the spike protein and the spike
protein we
make them into different sections for
instance we have the full length we have
the s1
s2 the rbd and we also of course have
the uh you know the rbd mutants
uh so the dark green colored proteins
are the development of these proteins
are completed
and this uh the little star here
indicates you know these proteins are
active
in terms of in in their in
in like enzymatic activity analysis
and of course some of these proteins are
still under development but
uh we're confident they will be
out from the pipeline zoom and in the
meantime we also developed
you know protein reagents for other
coronaviruses
um so
to together with the with the ones from
the source
covey ii and i think in collaboration of
nanomew we have developed this uh
sinomium
synonym uh chip which um
is a chip for detecting
any format of upper respiratory viral
infections
um in a in a relatively high throughput
format
so this is the basically the current so
this is the
brief overview of the current progress
and
now i'm going to take us
dive a little bit deeper into uh into
these uh
key components of the sars kov2 so first
of all of course
it's a spike and here shows the
the the s1 portion of the kobe 2 spike
proteins
that we expressed using the transient
heck 293
expression system so we make the protein
bearing different tags either his tag or
fc tag
and the proteins showed good homogeneity
and the purity and of course the protein
is active
and in its binding to the h2 receptor
and with the optimized uh
expression methods we can ensure the
minimum batch to batch
variations both in regard of their
homogeneity
as here shown here by three by the data
from three lots
and they're a binding affinity towards
ace two
um and you know the also shown here uh
the the
the binding infinity varies only a
little bit
uh between the between these three lots
here and the spike breath that the s1
protein has
already been used um in
in an assay to determine the serum
antibody from you know starts called v2
patient
um which shows which shows a very good
signal to noise ratio when comparing to
the
to the serum from healthy donor
and i think since i think it was but in
february when this
um when the reports started to come in
about the the mutations that has been
discovered
uh in in the spike protein and
especially this
um this mutation d614g has raised a lot
of eyebrows
um because of its dominance in the
in the in in the virus strings and also
in its
um potentially increased uh infectious
you know infectivity so um with that
we crea we also generate that the s1
portion
of this you know quote unquote mutant
and this
me this mutant has been produced in the
heck 293 cell as well
and it also has very good purity
and homogeneity over 95 percent as
judged by
um the uh by the sec chromatography
and in terms of binding affinity towards
the ace two
uh we tested these um this
characteristics using both
the elisa method as well as a bri
method and the the results um that we
discover is that
this mute this particular mutation did
not
alter uh the binding affinity of the
the s1 of the source cop2 to ace2
uh significantly which is not surprised
um
considering you know the location of
this mutation
is slightly further off from the the
receptor binding domain which carries
uh mainly carries out the uh you know
ace to binding
activity uh but in terms of the
infectious um you know the the ability
to infect
host cells we did created a pseudovirus
based on this um 614 g mutant
and interestingly we do obs observe
a significantly increased the
transduction flow change
um comparing to the you know quote
unquote wild type 614d
uh d variants and in use in
of course in our system and this is a
this trend actually agrees
with the the published record indicating
that
um this this mutation this uh the
614 g mutation uh did all
did increase the infectious ability of
of this virus and of course
besides the mutant in the
at the 6 14 position
there are various mutations been
reported in
in the rbd the receptor binding domain
as well
so as i mentioned earlier we were the
first company to
produce rbd recovery using a recombinant
protein expression method and this was
used in the structural studies
to review its interaction with the ace2
and with rbd we were also able to
generate a rapid
monoclonal antibody that showed very
good
virus specificity against kobe 2 but not
does not interact with the rb uh does
not
interact with rbd of other coronaviruses
which is a
good uh reagent for serological
assay development and of course now
which started tracking
the the mutations that are um indicated
in the
in the literature um that happens
um during this uh to the rbd
region so here are several examples of
the mute
of the mutant proteins that we've
already produced
and we test of course we tested their
binding affinity
with the ace ii using an elisa type of
form
allies type of assay and there are you
know
uh ups and downs regarding to their
binding affinity
um i would like to here i would like to
uh focus on the
uh the vs uh 360
367f mutation um which
which the result the results published
in the previous
uh publication indicates that it showed
an
increased binding affinity which we also
observed
uh in the elisa format and we contribute
that
increase of binding affinity towards the
replacement of the veiling side chain
with the
with the aromatic ring that could
somehow stabilize the
you know stabilizer region to make the
um to make this
uh interaction plane interaction plane
more
uh exposed and
uh there are and of course there are
reports indicating um
for the w436r mutant uh the
i think there were reported data
indicating also exerts some
increase in binding affinity but here we
only
uh we all we observed a slightly
decrease the binding affinity
binding affinity towards ace two uh we
and we i think we contribute that to its
um uh to its stability which
which is indicated by its monomer uh
content
in in the in the preparation so the
protein itself is somehow maybe
more more unstable and prone to
aggregate so that could somehow
affect the binding affinity towards the
ace too and i think with the library of
the rbd mutants and the library is still
expanding
uh for the for the time being
um these mutants can be used for you
know
uh to screening uh either neutralized
initialization antibodies
or to help validate uh serological
assays to see if they're as
effect as effective against these
mutants
as against the you know the
quote-unquote wild type which is
which is the published sequence so
here's just like a quick example so we
have this
copper we have generated a neutralizing
antibody
um which is the mouse monoclonal against
the
against the rbd and you can see as
if we introduce this mutation into into
the rbd region
uh we do observe the alteration in the
in terms of the binding affinity so the
binding towards the while the the wild
type
is tighter comparing to that of the
mutant so
in so this could be an indication that
uh some neutralizing antibiotic that the
efficacy of some neutralizing antibodies
or the sensitivity
of some detecting antibodies could
somehow be uh
compromised with the presence of you
know either one
or a combination of a few mutants so i
think
this mutant library is so this is why we
created this mutant library
um to help with the to help with to
ensure
uh the efficacy of the antibodies will
be um
um or or in
in an effort to screen a
like broad spectrum antibodies that can
um
recognize that can have up be as
effective
as the wild types and as the as the
mutants
so um here i would like to
uh quickly take a look at the
you know the insect cells derived spike
protein variants so the
um we can use we can the heck 293 is
our uh first go-to choice because of its
uh relative uh relatively fast speed in
terms of
developing these proteins but the insect
cells are
also very useful tools um in this
in in in this event uh you can see they
can produce the rbd
and they can produce s1 as well and with
very similar
but with you know small molecular weight
variations due to the extent of the
glycosylation
but they the proteins proteins produced
in both systems can interact
at similar binding affinity towards ace2
and insect cells are useful so for
instance
for those for the s2 portion of the
kobe 2 we did have some difficulty to
express
this uh this section using the
as a heck 293 in the beginning so
but the insect provide the insect cell
line provided us with a very good
alternative
um to produce to produce this protein so
then we can add this to our
cla to our product collection and here
shows a
uh essentially optimization effort that
we did
to uh stable to stabilize
the this uh the s2 portion of this
protein
and because it's like the trimer domain
so we're expecting it to form a
you know trimeric trimeric format but
we would prefer um you know we would
need to reduce the
um you know the aggregate the extent of
aggregates
so we performed a uh you know buffer
optimization effort
and which significantly inc reduces
reduced the extent of uh aggregations
and this um and the optimized and the
proteins in the optimize the buffer
showed a good um stability and the
recovery
uh after this uh freeze and some ex
trial experiments um which indicates
that
this buffer is at this point ideal for
the storage
of the of the s2 protein
and we can also uh make some
engineering efforts to make proteins
into
into trimers or to somehow enhance the
trimerization
process of the proteins so one
of such approach that we
take is to add a photon to the to the c
terminus of the of the fusion protein
so here we uh here i showed an example
so we add a photon to a to a wild type
virus protein and we also added
in the same time we altered several
amino acids in the photon domain
uh to make it lose its ability for
trimerization
and you can see a very obvious shift in
terms of the retention time
on the scc column and because of course
the photon is associated with you know
themselves with
non-covalent interactions they can be
disrupted
by reagents such as sds so we treat this
while
this protein with the wild type photon
with sds
and you can observe the somehow
dissociation
with the with the trimers and
the peak migrates more towards the
retention time
of the of the monomer essentially
so um the the the enhancement of this
trimerization
is actually quite useful in terms of uh
you know
improving the binding affinity of and
improving the
stability and the binding affinity of
the
of the source of the source cov2 spike
protein so here is an assay
we construct this spike protein with a
photon or without a photon of course
and we when we observed a 10 times
increase in the binding in the binding
affinity towards h2
which indicates the the trimerization
and the stabilization of the spike
protein bi-photon
is beneficial in terms of its
in terms of its activity so such efforts
has been
uh used to produce influenza ihf
proteins
rsv glycoproteins and of course as shown
here the spike protein
of salts called v2 and we are also
trying this
photon trimer on other virus
proteins as well and so this is a
i think it's a very interesting and
very practical method to enhance protein
trimerization and of course last but not
least i would like to
give a shout out to the e coli
expression system which allowed us to
uh express uh
nuclear capsid proteins so during this
optimization process
we optimize the temperatures duration of
the fermentation
to enhance the protein expression
as soluble as you know as a soluble
protein
and after purification and we do
observed
that the proteins are the the nuclear
capsule proteins are
present in a very stable oligomer uh
oligomeric format uh which can survive
uh like three times of freeze freeze and
some exp
cycles and with and this uh data
actually agrees very well with the
published record they indicate the full
length
of the the nuclear capsid should be
presented in the format of
a a ligament instead of a mon instead of
a monomer
and we also in the preview we also
expressed the
the nucleocapsid using
insect cell as insect system as well
and uh and from the
and i think from the data you can see
here the the protein expressed
in e coli shows a much better uh
profile in terms of its homogeneity
uh can when comparing to the counterpart
that is expressed in
uh in the insect cells and of course
with the
enhanced homogeneity it also showed
better
you know binding affinity or specificity
towards a
nuclear capsids and a protein specific
antibodies that we
generated
now i would like to change gear a little
bit to talk about this
beatmap high throughput recombinant
antibody production platform that we
have established
in order to you know facilitate
high screen high throughput antibody
screenings essentially
so basically what happens is that uh we
receive an antibody sequence library
from a client
and then we generate uh generate a
primer library corresponding to each
you know each construct using a high
throughput primer design and synthesized
platform
and then we convert these primers into
construction vectors
and of course then transiently transfect
the heck to 93 cell
culture array and after seven days of
culture
we can purify the antibody using one
step purification
which usually results in over 90
purity and then we send the antibodies
back to the client for validation
and uh they can pick up a few um
to uh to scale up so at this moment uh
the
the cultural volume of this platform is
said to be between
20 to 400 mil which will allows
us to obtain quantity between uh i would
i believe microgram to to milligram
scale
um you know at this high throughput
stage and there's the weekly capacity
uh is to produce 100 to 200 antibodies
and so far we have um completed of
course like over 15 projects in this
platform
in this platform and the over oh and the
average success rate
in terms of antibody expression is 85
percent
um so here is an example
that was a a
collaborative work that we have done in
earlier and the the clients has
collected b cells from the copy 19
patient and then they
synthesize they generate this antibody
sequence library
and we produced uh 632 antibodies using
the bitmap
and the antibodies were validated by
purity analysis and elisa to bind for
this
as either the s1 or the both the s1 and
rbd of the
of the kovi ii uh and the clients
identified 14 neutralizing antibodies
and
we help them with the scale up to 10
between 10 to 300 mix
and they use the antibody to for animal
studies as well as structural analysis
uh the results was published i think in
cell in
early april um and here is the reference
if you're interested so um
basically to uh to sum up so virus
proteins they're
crucial starting materials for uh drug
discoveries
and uh test development and we have
created a comprehensive protein library
for the source copy 2 and other coromal
viruses
and i would like to also focus on the
the spike
protein mutants um so they can be
they have a mutant library has been
created and
the um that we all we do observe some
alteration
in their uh binding affinity towards uh
towards phase two a uh receptor
and last but not least this high
throughput bitmap platform
can ensure efficient generation of both
recombinant proteins and antibodies
and i hope it will be uh useful for um
your uh for your research um
either in south korea too or in other
areas as well uh
so with that i would like to uh thank
all the
uh all the scientists and technicians
that work very hard
to make this uh to make these products
available
and hopefully with the help of these
recombinant proteins and antibodies
we should steer clear of this pandemic
sooner okay
so with that i would like to conclude
this presentation
if you're interested in learning more
about the reagents we have developed for
source code v2 please follow the links
on this slide
to find out more and you can always
contact us
via either phone or email with that
thank you for your attention
and i would be happy to take any
questions
thank you dr chen for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
how is phenobiological involved in the
race of developing a vaccine for coven
19.
thank you so um i think it's
safe to say that we're not directly
involved in their uh developing of a
vaccine
but we do provide um the scientific
community
uh with all the uh with a variety of
reagents
that are available to um
to assay the uh for the efficacy
of of the vaccine so uh we're uh
essentially playing a role of a helper
uh
rather than a direct competitor in in
in this race for the for the covenant
vaccine
now what are the challenges in
expressing the spike protein and
any suggestions on how to improve spike
protein stability
well i think spike protein is
intrinsically very
difficult to work with because it is
so first of all it's a very very
flexible protein it's
compo it has
i would say it can be divided into three
major portions
the the s1 ver the s1 region s2 region
as well as anything that is associated
with the membrane
so that alone gives us gives
a lot of complex complexity to work uh
to begin with
and also this protein is heavily
modulated
after after you know
post-translationally
it's heavily glycosylated and in order
for the spike to work
it has to be processed by two enzymes
the the ace2
and another enzyme that is associated
with its uh cleavage
so uh so with these you know in the
enzymatic processing site it contributes
to the instability it's the
endogenous instability of the protein so
so basically the recombinant protein
expression is a raised between
the generation of a protein and the
degradation of a protein
so the the instability factors within
the spike protein contributes greatly to
its instability
so so that's why i think uh before the
uh for the paper that uh revealed that
firstly review the structure of the
spike protein
they use the version called the called
prefusion where
they eliminated the fearing cleavage
sites
for one thing and also they
introduced the several mutations to the
s2 s2 region of the protein to make it
more stable
so i think uh in terms of to so i think
that's a reflection of how
difficult it is to how to make these
to make this protein and i think uh
with the time uh when the time goes on
uh i think there are more and more
uh versions of the spike has been
produced um
and then recently there's a publication
uh
that reported a uh more stable
version of the protein called hexapro
which they
introduced the six perling residue uh
six mutations on the s2
region um to change them into prolines
to further stabilize the stabilize the
protein
so i think one
a key method to improve the stability of
the spike protein
is to introduce i wouldn't say as many
mutations as possible but rationally
so based on the structure of the protein
rationally designed
where design what kind of mutations and
how many mutated residues should be
introduced to the protein to
to one to for one thing and prove its
uh to previous stability and also in the
meantime
to monitor its activity in terms of
binding to the h2 receptor to make sure
that it's
stable and in the meantime without
sacrifice
any ac2 binding activity so there's not
you know too much we can do in the
protein expression and purification per
se
but i think that this is uh the place
where
protein engineering and the person
sequence analysis methods really uh
really shine and i think they can
provide us with more uh tools
to to to to to solve this issue and to
improve the
stability of the spike protein
thank you so much for that answer dr
chen so our next question
is how do you choose the most suitable
system
for sars kobe 2 protein expression
um so i think as i mentioned briefly in
the in the presentation itself
uh so source cov2 has a proteom
of uh maybe like 25 proteins and
besides the spike protein and and the
nuclear capsid protein
you know many of the more enzymes um so
i think the the in order to choose the
most the suitable syst
so i think we can take a look at this
question from
two perspectives so from a pure
uh you know research perspective um
we would uh uh to choose a suitable
system we would
uh require it to produce the protein at
a
at a good yield and at a
acceptable biological activity uh
however uh
i think during this time because the
develop because the speed is the key
we you know to in order to
develop uh serological analysis
tools as fast as possible so it would
require us
to choose to choose a
system that could give us uh you know
something to begin with and then we
uh and then based on that information we
uh start to um to optimize
in order to you know to increase the
increase the yield and
and maybe to optimize the the protein
activity
so but but the general guideline
is so it's like time uh it has
it has something to do with the
production time so we would like to
choose a system that can
give us the protein is as fast as
possible
but in the meantime i think uh the
the choice will also be uh you know to
produce a protein that is
uh biologically as biologically relevant
as possible so for this so for instance
for the spike protein
the the first line of choices will be
the heck 293
and the insects because they can add as
much post-translational modifications as
possible
to the protein which you know these
factors are indeed very important for
the you know the biological function of
the protein
but for the enzymes of the of the of the
sarcoid
ii i think we're more
concerned or we're more care about their
functionalities and i think if
a prokaryote system in our case the e
coli system will be
more than enough to produce these pro
to produce the active form of these
proteins for us
um so i think that so we went for
uh of course for the e coli first but
the eukaryote system from for instance
insect cells can also give us some
you know alternatives just in case uh if
the
uh the e coli fail to express the
protein or it fails to
produce an active form of the protein
so basically we would need a
uh a first line of choice so
either hecto93 or or the insect
oh sorry or the e coli for you know
different proteins and
we also would have uh like essentially
like a back
plant in this case and in our case is
the insect
system so um yeah so so with that
i think it's a comprehensive uh chosen
of hosts
to um yeah to to express the
the source cov2 proteins
thank you now what is the intended use
of the rbd mutants and in what format
are they supplied
yeah so i think the first
reported rbd mutants were
appeared in literature actually very
early during this pandemic i think
somewhere in march so that's where we
started to you know pay attention to
these mutants
because uh they can
they can either be benign and you know
didn't do anything or
they can alter the um
alter either binding to the h2 or the
you know essentially the virulence of
the virus
and i think uh you know with the
progression of the time there are many
studies
in um also pay attention to the you know
to these rbd mutants
and they use like pseudo-virus analysis
to um to somehow study these mutants and
they there are indication that with
certain mutations
uh the virus could be more infectious
and it could also uh maybe
invade uh the you know the neutralizing
initializing antibodies that have been
generated by
and you know by patients or by other
meth
by other laboratory methods so i think
that's why we
uh um we're quite uh focused on the
uh where we devoted a lot of energy to
produce a library of these
uh you know rbd mutants i think they're
important for uh either
for both you know the the uh the
serological
assays to validate you know if this
athlete is
as sensitive as um to the to the
quote unquote wild type versus you know
these these mutants
and also i think it could um if if you
have like a therapeutic antibody
uh i think people would be also
interested in
to see if the therapeutic antibody is
going to be as
effective you know against these mutants
as the as a quote-unquote wild-type uh
wild-type string
and i think a fast method to you know
study
to to to investigate the you know the
efficacy of the antibody against the
mutants
would be to screen it you know for the
binding to these mutants
uh uh instead of uh you know using a
pseudoviral
acid you know of course the the virus as
it has has its merits but
it would take some you know time to
develop but you know with the proteins
available you can
you know directly do the screening which
will uh you know
give indications of the efficacy of the
antibody and
also saves the developers some time i
think
and the rpg mutants are formed so
they they're supplied in you know
individual formats of course
so you can order you know one mutant
at the you know the mutant of your
interest and
i think we're also uh trying to make
them into a
into like a semi uh high surface
screening format so to put them into
a onto a plate so that you can
you know stream multiple mutants at a
time so
uh to essentially to speed up the
uh the the r d process for uh you know
anti um at
source code to antibody development
all right so just to remind our audience
uh
we do only have time for a few more
questions so just as a reminder
the any questions that we don't are
unable to answer today and those that
come in during the on-demand period
will be answered by dr chen via the
email address that you provided at the
time of registration
so we'll move on to our next one which
is can i use
foldon in my prokaryo expression system
uh this is uh uh this is an interesting
question
uh so i think the short answer is yes so
i've read uh some
literature um they used the photon in
the in the e coli to produce a stable
chimer
a format of a protein but i would like
to
or you know urge our listeners and or
you know the researchers to to pay
attention
uh so um even though photon can do
you know a lot of things in our case can
make tri
uh trimers for uh for the virus proteins
but
uh we would need to consider the you
know the protein itself before we
proceed
to add uh this tribalization domain or
any other uh you know oligomerization
domains
um uh to the protein because once
because we're essentially forcing
uh the proteins together to form a
higher degree
of i wouldn't say aggregates but
form a higher degree of association with
themselves so if the protein itself
if there are some you know instability
issue stability regions reside within
the protein itself
it could cause it could be problematic
in in their production so
i think uh so i think yes you can use
the phone in the prokaryo system
uh but you i but i think it would be
sensible to take a very careful look at
the protein sequence
uh to to to you know anticipate any
uh problems that might associate it uh
with the you know association of the
of association or the tribalization of
the target proteins
it looks like we have time for one more
question so dr chen
what is the advantage of the vitemab
system
and have you created a recombinant
protein library using this platform
uh yeah so the the bitmap system
is basically a derivative of our
you know heck 293 protein expression
pipeline
so i think the advantage of the i think
the most
the biggest advantage of this bitmap
system
is that with the information and so we
so with the information from the system
we can directly
assess the scalability of an antibody
so you know some antibodies can be
produced at a high level and
other antibodies you know the
expression level varies based on the
antibody sequence
um but with the bitmap we can so first
we can
we can screen you can literally express
like hundreds of antibodies
uh in a short period of time like in a
week or two
to help create the the library that with
the
with a decent size for you know for the
client to
to screen and the information
about the antibody expression level
would allow us
to um you know to from another
perspective to
to select you know the the candidates
that are
that are essentially most uh uh most
could uh add uh that they're essentially
be more you know successful in terms of
a
high level expression um
so so with these uh you know with the
with the two
i think it will be it will provide the
client with a relatively clear picture
of
you know which candidates they would
like to uh select
and to move on to you know scale up
production
and also the the i think the information
that
the yield bit from the
i think the small scale production could
be directly
translated into the into the yield from
from the scale up so
uh so based on the information of the of
the pilots of the small scale
we wouldn't know how much protein or
antibody we would be able to get
so that could i think also provide as it
could also be you know advantageous
uh in terms of the scale of the
production of
any uh given antibodies and for
uh for the protein life so we also so we
do have
uh tried a few times uh using the bitmap
system to create a recombinant protein
library
and i think the uh the most recent event
would be uh we collaborated with
uh distributed bio and uh we created a
uh
library uh two libraries for them
actually uh
for uh uh for some uh influenza
uh ha and na proteins uh but
uh i think the uh the recombinant
protein library is a little bit trickier
um than their antibody library because
you know proteins are more versatile
um so we anticipate more
problems in terms of their
in terms of of their productivity in
this system but
but i think at the end of the day uh uh
it's still it's still proven to be a
very useful system
and uh we delivered over
i think over 85 of of the of the
targeted proteins in in these two
libraries
thank you again dr chen do you have any
final comments for our audience
um yeah so i would like to you know take
this opportunity to thank the organizers
and of course you know this pandemic is
far from over
so um uh please wear a mask and
you know keep social distancing and uh
you know stay safe
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by dr trend via the
contact information that you provided at
the time of registration
we would like to once again thank dr
chen for his time today and for his
important research
we would also like to thank labbert and
our sponsor xenobiological for
underwriting today's educational webcast
you can view the webinar on demand
labrets will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
that's all for now thank you for joining
us and until next time
bye-bye